kölle alaaf das verboten vom elfen
helfen darf man nicht geschafft uns
richten mal ärger erst auf dem elfen
helfen
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video leute wir haben
gerade relativ früh am morgen und heute
steht was äußerst interessantes an und
zwar bis es ja wahrscheinlich die
meisten von euch eventuell auch nicht
aber dann lernt leute kennen uns ja wohl
nicht an köln
und hier ist in genau vier tagen
karnevalsbeginn nämlich die rechte
hälfte vom lvl und wir haben heute eine
ganz spezielle mission begeben wir uns
unter dem motto stadt land kuss auf die
spuren des carnevals also wer kunden so
ein bisschen die stadt kommenden termin
mit jemandem aus dem karneval fortan
ihren können der uns ein paar coole
fragen beantwortet das ganze einen
stillen kompression mit der deutschen
waren die hier auch eng werden kann weil
zusammenarbeiten und uns
freundlicherweise ein paar tickets zur
verfügung gestellt haben mit denen wir
jetzt gleich ganz entspannt hier vom
bahnhof in die stadt kommt und dann
würde ich sagen fahr los in die
innenstadt
ich bin gespannt was ich selber so alles
heute erfahren werde und ja ich habe
lust selbst glaubt so leute wir sind
jetzt hier am bahnhof angekommen und
haben schon gesagt wir haben im korb
bekommen
das heißt wir können das hier ist ganz
entspannt unserer fahrer es tickets ihn
db regio nrw dann nämlich zwei
verschiedene angebote einmal das vsg 24
stunden ticket mit dem ihr halt 24
stunden durch bestimmte städte und
gemeinden im vrs gebiet reisen könnt
oder das schöner tag vergeht nrw welches
halt für ganz nrw gilt ihr könnt
entweder beiden tickets alleine fahren
oder in gruppen zu bis zu fünf personen
und wir sind jetzt zwei personen das
heißt sie brauchen zwei mal ein vst geld
und mal den stoff zu kommen
[Musik]
so jetzt hat es geklappt hier das thema
für dich alles klar manchmal sagen
abbruch zum zug
[Musik]
ähnlich im zug ist das nächste schönes
wetter wie man sieht ist aber ganz
angenehme und wir fahren jetzt in die
innenstadt vorbei am wunderschönen
verregneten können
[Musik]
ich habe mich übrigens auch schon
passend angezogen heute könne das
verboten von elfen helfen darf man nicht
mal ärger erst auf dem eltern die leute
da draußen gucken alle schon so blöd was
damit wir hier los ist
heißt
[Musik]
leute wir sind jetzt mittlerweile schon
angekommen am heumarkt und sind jetzt
auf dem weg hier zur bühne weil da
wartet der herr schlegel wird ob uns das
ist der vorstand von einem ganz
besonderen karnevalsvereine hier in köln
und dann sollen wir jetzt mal los geht's
die willi ostermann ist schiffe oder am
28 februar 1967 in köln gegründet heute
gehört sie zu den größten
karnevalsverein der stadt veranstaltet
abwechslungsreiche karnevalssitzungen
und ist für die traditionelle saison
eröffnung am elften elften auf dem
heumarkt zustände ich habe den
vorsitzenden herrn stelle mich getroffen
und konnte ihm ein paar fragen über
mythen und geschichten des carnevals
stellen also leute werden jetzt gerade
hier unsere position geändert stehen
jetzt noch mal genau vor der bühne und
ich habe jetzt so ein paar mythen
rausgesucht dass karneval diese gern mal
kurz und knackig erklären können und
zwar fangen wir vielleicht direkt beim
ersten und damit er erst mit dem ersten
mythos an
wieso ist die jungfrau ein mann also wir
haben 1823 mit dem organisierten
karneval in köln angefangen und das war
in der zeit definitiv eine menge
dominierte geschichte jungfrau
verkörpert auch einen anderen mythos der
dahintersteckt 11.000 jungfrauen das ist
auch im kölner stadtwappen mal durch die
tränen ausgedrückt die senderstadt mal
gehabt und ja was ist was die belastung
angeht hat man halt immer ein mann
genommen
das hat sich einfach so ergeben das ist
verboten worden
während des zweiten weltkriegs gab es
gar kein dreigestirn in der form doch da
gab es ein
aber da war das sogar eine frau weil das
nicht für die führung damals da opportun
war
danach hat man das aus traditionellen
gründen geändert und verhalten ja gern
an traditionen fest ja und jetzt wegen
ist auch heute noch ok und sie haben
gerade schon das dreigestirn
angesprochen
ich weiß nicht ob das ob das jedem so
ein häufiger begriff ist was sind da die
aufgaben oder vor allem jeder karneval
feiern stellt ja dreigestirn also es
gibt nicht verschiedene karnevalsvereine
die ein dreigestirn es gibt nur ein
einziges ein einziges pro karnevalszeit
programmcodes ist also köln gibt es nur
eins in köln gibt es nur eins muss sich
geheime offizielle es gibt einen
gewissen stadträndern gibt es eigene
aber dass das zelt nicht zu und das
festkomitee kölner karneval was in den
großen karneval organisiert und
gestaltet stellt ein dreigestirn diese
jungs kommen aus verschiedenen
gesellschaften
und da gibt es ein wahlverfahren und man
kann sich bewerben und dann werden
hoffentlich immer die besten ausgesucht
die das dann verkörpert ok und warum
gibt es dann dreigestirn das dreigestirn
verkörpert die stadt stadt köln
der bauer der steht für für die
schutzmaßnahme in einer stadt wie rauch
aus dem mittelalter und dann gab es eine
stadtmauer
das kann man auch erkennen weil ja einen
großen schlüsselbund trägt das sind die
schlüssel für die stadttore die werden
immer zum anfang einer karnevalszeit von
dem jeweiligen oberbürgermeister bei uns
in köln ist es eine oberbürgermeisterin
der stadt ist das schon ein bisschen
weiter wieder karneval
seine frau und die schlüssel übergeben
um halt auch die gewalt zu übertragen
in der karnevalszeit bestimmt halt
dieses närrische
dreigestirn das närrische trifolium die
geschicke der stadt und nach narkosen
montags werden dann diese gewaltigen
wieder zurückgegeben
die oberbürgermeisterin jungfrau wie
gesagt verkörpert historie auch der
stadt köln mit den 11.000 jungfrauen
dieses mal gab und der prinz ist der
absolute mittelpunkt das ist der held
karneval
anderen beiden zusammenhält und
gemeinsam die närrische botschaft in das
volk hinaus geben und eine sache die
mich auch noch ziemlich interessiert und
zwar ich kenne das aus meiner
heimatstadt auch da werden ja zum
karneval immer massen an bonbons
geworfen war das auch schon immer so
oder wie ist das entstanden
ja und er hat halt süßigkeiten dann an
die andere an das volk gegeben die den
rosenmontagszug besuchen
bonbons macht man heute nicht mehr so
weiß ich alles auch weiter entwickelt
habt die sind zu klein und keiner wird
sich mehr danach
heute sind das sagt schon eher
schokoladen und mal eben und strüßjer
okay weil ich habe jetzt letztes jahr
auf den straßen ging ja dann auch am
nächsten tag noch ziemlich viel oder
liegt ja noch ziemlich wiederum habe ich
immer noch viele bonbons gesehen muss
ich sagen na ja gut er ist war dann aber
auch schon oder es wahrscheinlich schon
seit vielen jahren so dass hier der
heimat das ja der hauptplatz eigentlich
ne für für alles auch am rosenmontag
oder was ich dann oder hier treten ja
die ganzen bands auf kann man das so
sagen dass sich das meiste immer hier
abgespielt hat oder gibts da irgendwie
noch einen anderen ort der bedeutsam ist
alles hat sich immer überwiegend in der
innenstadt abgespielt
frühjahr hatte der rosenmontagszug man
ganz andere strecke bevor man um den
neumarkt der sich in unmittelbarer nähe
aber wir der heumarkt ein teil der
altstadt genau wie der alter markt oder
rund um den dom das ist schon das
epizentrum
das kann man gar nicht alles klar er
danke für ihre zeit und ich wünsche mir
noch viel spaß hier werden aufbauende
ist ja noch nicht ganz fertig sein
leute wieder zu hause angekommen genau
jetzt ist die sonne rausgekommen es hat
den ganzen morgen leider gerechnet und
jetzt kommen die so daraus naja ist ja
typisch leute die sagen jetzt ganz schön
lange unterwegs auch wenn ihr zuhause
nicht so viel ein kontakt mit karneval
kann ja sein kommt ja auf die region an
hoffe ich natürlich dass es euch
trotzdem gefallen hat und in ein
bisschen etwas gelernt habe also ich
habe auf jeden fall was gelernt ich
hoffe es dadurch gefallen lassen nach
oben da steckt ja meine instagram post
ab und so zum thema haut rein
dollar